hey clutter fans John Roker here with
another video for Collider quick so you
saw the recent trailers for the one
spider-man villain that could make even
gene Simmons of kiss a little jealous
that's right we're talking about
everyone's favorite long tongue talking
all black all yours it symbiote you know
who I'm talking about
venom ever since this film was announced
and Tom Hardy was cast as its star the
talk all over the interwebs has been if
spider-man can be in the MCU does that
mean venom might find his body more fun
but hanging out with the Avengers too
and hobnobbing with Kevin Feige well it
depends on who you ask
former Sony head and current venom
producer Amy Pascal said venom would be
an adjunct to the MCU and exist in the
same reality now she did Walker comments
back quickly after but she didn't walk
them all the way back then ruben
fleischer Venom's director would neither
confirm nor deny a Tom Holland aka
spider-man cameo in the film Marvel
producer Kevin Feige however said that
for now there is no plan for venom in
the MCU it's a Sony project
spider-man homecoming director John
watts later reaffirmed that and said
that venom was not connected to the
Marvel world and then Avengers infinity
war co-director Joe Russo joined the
chorus and said no that's a Sony
property well I hate indecision Collider
fans so I'm gonna go ahead and let you
know how venom could be a part of the
MCU anyway regardless of what Marvel's
legal team and their creative control
people do and say over at MCU first look
to the recent news that broke about Sony
dropping the rating of venom from a
strong are possibility to a safe and
cuddly pg-13 this makes it easier to
slide the never rated are MCU characters
in and out of both universes deftly also
they are setting venom in San Francisco
and not New York which indicates that
Tom Hardy was right when he revealed at
the South Paulo comic convention that
the film would be using the lethal
protector storyline as its basis he also
threw in his mumble two cents and said
that the best way to get venom into the
MCU is to use one of the best storylines
involving the character and one that is
limited MCU characters in it the
approach makes sense when you look at
lethal protector - it has a truce
between Eddie Brock and spider-man which
allows Brock to move to San Francisco
he eventually becomes an auntie hero
without having an annoying spider-man
pushing his weight what is that video
no not an ant hero an antihero anyways
he's hunted down by something called The
Life Foundation which first made its
appearance in the Amazing Spiderman line
of comic books and who was looking to
capture Brock's
Simba Simba my Simba damn it I gotta get
that right they eventually do and end up
making five clones of venom from the
trailers you've already seen this looks
like it might be happening in the film
as well with Rizzo meds cletus Katie as
one of the clones named a riot people
were wanting a carnage appearance which
this guy do in the vo here doesn't think
is out of the question yet but getting
riot is interesting since venom and
Spidey team up to take him down in the
lethal protector series there's been a
lot of rumors of Tom Hollander making an
appearance in venom so could this be how
it happens and what Spidey appears in
venom then we have ourselves an MCU
venom people now if you establish that
Eddie Brock / venom could easily exist
in a world where a man and pym
enterprises are residents of San
Francisco as well then it would be
totally believable that he wouldn't
interact with them since he's a
low-level reporter right however when he
has trouble figuring out how to control
his sim by keyword or Simbi some role
Jesus I gotta get that right then he
logically turned to the PIMs and Janet
Van Dyne they're scientists and have a
carry on laboratory that they can use to
cure Eddie Brock or at least control
venom so now you have a new city to
create a venom / MCU crossover in that
doesn't require you crossing the streams
with too many MCU characters in New York
City and risk messing with the MCU
cannon of any of those characters one of
the way that venom could be in the MCU
and one that I love even though it's a
crazy long shot
even longer the Venom's creepy effing
tongue is the old-school approach venom
first appeared in issue number 8 of The
Secret Wars comic book limited series
when spider-man commissioned a new
uniform from a machine and the heroes
lair in space
it's that badass all-black outfit we've
already seen in the trailers but one we
find out is a simple symbol
damnit I'm not saying that word again
anyways it's an outerspace creature and
where did we see spider-man last when he
got dusted oh yeah in space sure he did
have the iron spider outfit but maybe he
comes back and doesn't have that Iron
Man special on his back he'd need a new
outfit right and where might he be when
he comes back oh yeah on an outerspace
planet with alien technology so would he
attract a certain alien creature on
Titan or whatever planet he ends up on
before coming back to earth certainly a
possibility this would then make venom a
near-future story told after the events
of Avengers 4 and will give new meaning
to the Spider Man far from home title of
the sequel to homecoming don't tell me
that new black background for this film
couldn't possibly be teasing this
possibility don't look at me like that
it's possible anyways we'll all find
this out soon enough as venom comes out
on October 5th and will answer all your
questions about the possibility of it
crossing over into the MCU but until
then I hope this video gave you a
glimpse into a couple of ways that venom
could show up in the MC oh okay that's
it for me remember to like this video
and share it on your social media also
subscribe to our channel to get more
videos just like this symbiote symbiote
simple how do you say this damn word
symbiosis
symbiotic